bedroht künstliche intelligenz ki die
menschheit oder ist sie im gegenteil ein
segen künstliche intelligenz ist längst
in der praxis angekommen und wird in
fast allen bereichen eingesetzt von der
medizin über den straßenverkehr bis hin
zum militär haftet ki demnächst
persönlich für schäden die sie anrichten
wie ein mensch oder eskalieren kriege in
der zukunft zwischen killer bot armeen
innerhalb von tagen oder stunden
wie kriegen wir also die ki geregelt
denn wenn nicht droht eine ganz andere
art von zombie apokalypse klicks um
science and future geht es montags
mittwochs und freitags spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion von ix entstanden das
fachmagazin informiert über alle
wegweisenden entwicklungen im it bereich
und am ende könnt ihr euch eine digitale
ausgabe gratis sichern oder auf den link
unten in der video beschreibung klicken
sie gilt als schlüsseltechnologie für
die zukunft und begleitet uns bereits im
alltag wenn wir unsere smartphones per
gesichtserkennung entsperren und dann
fragen wie das wetter wird oder wenn wir
unsere einparkhilfe im auto benutzen
oder uns von alexa einen witz erzählen
lassen ständig ist ki im einsatz die
künstliche intelligenz vereinfacht
gesagt handelte sich dabei um ein
computerprogramm das selbstständig
handeln und auch entscheidungen treffen
kann indem es auf eine riesige menge an
gespeicherten daten zurückgreift vom
marketing über die medizin und forschung
bis hin zum straßenverkehr ist heute
kaum noch wegzudenken auch in der
astrophysik werden dadurch immer wieder
neue erkenntnisse gewonnen doch mit der
technologie sind nicht nur große
hoffnung sondern auch große ängste bis
hin zu untergangsszenarien verbundenen
musk waren sie zum beispiel vor
marodierenden ki robotern die alle
umbringen
eine zombie apokalypse der besonderen
art das stellt uns vor der
herausforderung ethische und rechtliche
rahmenbedingungen für den einsatz von ki
festzulegen denn nur so können wir
verhindern dass die ki die macht
übernimmt davon zumindest sind viele
fachleute überzeugt und vielleicht
deshalb sind viele unternehmen noch sehr
sehr vor sich
viele unternehmen hierzulande sind
nämlich noch unsicher wenn es darum geht
wie und wann sie einsetzen sollen im
september letzten jahres wurden dazu 600
unternehmensvertreter in deutschland
befragt und tatsächlich sind erst bis
zum jahr 2023 wirklich hohe
budgetsteigerung für den einsatz von
künstlicher intelligenz in den betrieben
geplant
aber obwohl hier kurzfristig noch keine
allzu hohen summen investiert werden
stufen die unternehmen das potenzial der
technologie schon als sehr hoch ein
mal sehen ob es uns dabei so geht wie
bei der elektromobilität bei der
deutsche autohersteller ja den anschluss
vollkommen verpasst haben wie sie selbst
zugeben die krux ist dass sie auch den
organisatorischen aufwand als sehr hoch
einschätzen der nötig ist um ki in den
unternehmen zu implementieren km
bedeutet immer auch dass es einen
wechsel im denken geben muss und eine
weitere hürde sind eben die vielen
fragen die damit einhergehen weil es
bisher kaum leitlinien für den einsatz
von ki gibt ohne die wird es schwierig
die ängste der mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen und kunden zu beruhigen
und vor allem auch die risiken zu
beschränken
wir haben hier schon öfter über die
fehlleistungen von kiwi zum beispiel
rassismus bei der medizinischen
behandlung von schwarzem menschen die
dort durch die ki lange benachteiligt
wurden berichtet die drängenden fragen
lauten was macht ki mit unserer
gesellschaft wie verändert sie unsere
arbeit und wie stellen wir sicher dass
sie zum wohle der menschen agiert um das
zu beantworten ist im märz das
observatorium künstliche intelligenz in
arbeit und gesellschaft des
bundesministeriums für arbeit und
soziales gestartet es soll sicherstellen
dass ki verantwortungsvoll eingesetzt
wird doch was steckt alles hinter der
frage wie wir sicherstellen können dass
die technologie interesse der menschen
und im interesse des gemeinwohls genutzt
wird denn eins ist ziemlich klar gut
eingesetzt kann ki dafür sorgen dass
niemand mehr auf der welt hungern muss
für wohlstand chancengleichheit bildung
und so weiter und so fort
die aufgaben des observatoriums gliedern
sich in fünf teile hier im
schnelldurchlauf erster technologie
vorzeit und technikfolgenabschätzung
hier soll abgesetzt werden was kann
jetzt und in zukunft mit unserer arbeit
und der gesellschaft macht dazu werden
vor allem makroökonomische entwicklungen
analysieren also der blick auf das
gesamt wird
schaftliche geschehen und nicht auf
einzelne betriebe der schwerpunkt liegt
auf der analyse der situation von
beschäftigten in betrieben
hier wird sozusagen die frage gestellt
wie kann die arbeit für jeden einzelnen
und damit für die gesamte gesellschaft
verändern wird zum beispiel ob sie zur
massenarbeitslosigkeit führen wird dabei
arbeitet man mit sozialpartnern und
internationalen organisationen zusammen
darunter die oecd die organisation für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung die sich auf 37
mitgliedstaaten zusammensetzt die
wohlstand gleichheit chancen und
wohlbefinden fördern wollen
die meisten mitglieder sind übrigens
ländern mit hohem pro kopf einkommen
also keine entwicklungsländer außerdem
arbeitet man mit der yellow zusammen der
internationalen arbeitsorganisation das
ist eine organisation der vereinten
nationen die sich für soziale
gerechtigkeit menschen und arbeitsrechte
einsetzt man sieht also schon in welche
richtung das geht und was hier
sichergestellt werden soll
in der arbeits und sozialverwaltung im
zweiten handlungsfeld steht die frage im
mittelpunkt wie ki verwaltungsprozesse
für bürgerinnen und bürger besser machen
kann
das kann ja wirklich eine erhebliche
erleichterung für uns alle bedeuten
sollen kriterien festgelegt werden mit
denen die anwendung dann ausgewählt und
eingesetzt werden dazu muss man
festlegen welche anforderungen die
technologie in bezug auf ihre qualität
ihre nachvollziehbarkeit und fairness
erfüllen muss drittens der
ordnungsrahmen für ki und soziale
technikgestaltung hier sollen die
anforderungen aus punkt 2 in kriterien
ausformuliert werden im vordergrund
steht die frage wie man die
schnittstelle zwischen mensch und ki
gestaltet denn es entstehen so zur
technische systeme also solche bei denen
es wechselwirkung zwischen sozialen und
technischen systemen gibt das bedeutet
dass unsere bestehenden prinzipien und
regeln überarbeitet werden müssen sie
müssen angepasst werden an die ki
viertens aufbau internationaler und
europäischer strukturen es sollen
internationale regeln für einen
verantwortungsvollen umgang mit ki
geschaffen werden und die nötigen
institutionen die diese überwachen
für die internationalen standards sind
übrigens neben dem mitgliedstaaten der
eu auch japan die usa und kanada länder
mit denen man sich austauscht fünftens
gesellschaftlicher dialog und vernetzung
es soll eine möglichst breite
bevölkerungsgruppe mit in die arbeit
einbezogen werden um schlussendlich die
ganze gesellschaft vom
profitieren zu lassen und das ist ein
ziemlich wichtiger punkt zusammengefasst
arbeitet das ob saturn also aus wie die
prognosen für die gesellschaftlichen
veränderungen durch die aussehen was die
anforderung an ki sind damit sie der
gesellschaft nutzt und zwar der gesamten
gesellschaft und wie die neuen regeln
für das zusammenwirken von mensch und
maschine aussehen und wie solche regeln
international gewährleistet werden
können zusammengefasst arbeitet das
observatorium also aus wie die prognosen
für die gesellschaftlichen veränderungen
durch ki aussehen was die anforderungen
an ki sind damit sie der gesellschaften
nutzt wie die neuen regeln für das
zusammenwirken von mensch und maschine
aussehen und wie solche regeln
international gewährleistet werden
können und eine weitere extrem wichtige
frage in bezug auf ki ist wer am ende wo
verhaftet dazu tut sich gerade einiges
auf europäischer ebene die eu plant ki
haftungsregelung die einen rechtsrahmen
zur nutzung von ki in der europäischen
union geben diese regeln sollen
einerseits die verbraucher schützen und
andererseits innovationen in unternehmen
fördern
die basis dazu soll ein risikobasierte
ansatz sein also die abwägung ob ein ki
system eher wenig oder besonders
risikobehaftet ist dementsprechend soll
es für die systeme dann strenge oder
weniger strenge regularien und
kontrollen geben das kann man sich gut
am beispiel ki basierter systeme in
fahrzeugen vorstellen
diese sind mit einem hohen risiko
behaftet weil sie unfälle verursachen
können und eine konkrete forderung
lautet deshalb dass halter solcher wagen
sich speziell versichern müssen wobei
das in dem fall eigentlich billiger
werden müsste weil ja weniger unfälle
bauen zu können zum einen mögliche
schäden gering gehalten beziehungsweise
versichert werden und die unternehmen
die solche fahrzeuge entwickeln können
innovationen vorantreiben ohne die sorge
dass sie im schadensfall haftbar gemacht
werden selber haften kann die ki
schließlich nicht dabei gab es
zwischenzeitlich sogar die heftige idee
eine rechtsperson für ki systeme zu
schaffen also eine elektrische person
die haftet also die ki der bot quasi als
person und nicht als sache der
persönlich haftet das wäre schon
ziemlich verrückt gewesen
doch dafür müsste sie erst mal mit
startkapital ausgestattet werden und wo
soll das wiederum herkommen die idee im
zweifelsfall den
botta zu verklagen ist also wieder vom
tisch angepasst wird für die
haftungsfragen übrigens die
produkthaftung richtlinie aus dem jahr
1985 das eu parlament will damit
verbraucher besser vor fehlurteilen
durch ki schützen
die zugrunde liegenden algorithmen der
ki sollen dafür nachvollziehbar sein und
die datensätze auf denen sie basieren
müssen einem hohen qualitätsstandard
gerecht werden damit sie menschen nicht
diskriminieren ein grundsatz der heute
schon zum beispiel hier bei youtube
überhaupt nicht eingehalten wird kein
entwickler kann einem sagen warum der
algorithmus was genau macht und das ist
überhaupt nicht gut die
entscheidungsprozesse der km müssen in
zukunft überprüfbar und nachvollziehbar
sein dazu soll das recht der verbraucher
kommen eine menschliche überprüfung der
ki entscheidungen zu übernehmen und sie
gegebenenfalls aufzuheben wenn am
beispiel des fahrzeugs also das system
entscheidet das tempo beizubehalten muss
der fahrer sich trotzdem für eine
vollbremsung entscheiden können dabei
argumentieren die eu-abgeordneten damit
dass man so die akzeptanz des einsatzes
von ki system erhöhen kann denn ki die
man als mensch selbst nicht korrigieren
damit beherrschen kann löst große ängste
aus und das obwohl ki statistisch
gesehen meistens die besseren
entscheidungen fest zb bauen deutlich
weniger unfälle weil hier ki eingreift
wenn es gefährlich wird was gut klingt
hat übrigens trotzdem viele fachleute
enttäuscht weil die einstufungen hohes
oder niedriges risiko viel zu
undifferenziert ist diese und weitere
vorschläge der eu-kommission liegen im
weißbuch zur künstlichen intelligenz vor
und basieren auf dem ideal der
vertrauenswürdigkeit damit sind sie
zumindest indirekt ethik basiert das
problem bei der vertrauenswürdigkeit ist
aber die definition denn die systeme
können zuverlässig und möglichst
transparent sein aber trotzdem so
eingesetzt werden dass sie gegen die
eigentliche intention der richtlinie
genutzt werden das passiert bereits bei
konzernen wie facebook oder google und
selbst bei europäischen regierungen wie
ungarn oder polen die ki zur
unterstützung ihrer totalitären systeme
nutzen
positiv ist aber dass die eu die themen
klimaschutz und nachhaltigkeit mit
einbeziehen will sollen synergien
zwischen der ki forschung und dem
european green deal
und so die zukunft von intelligenten
umwelttechnologien gefördert werden doch
die wird nicht nur in bereichen
eingesetzt wo sie auf verbraucher trifft
ein besonders heikler einsatzbereich ist
das militär
hier braucht es schon längst keine
bomben mehr um ein land zu stabilisieren
es reicht ein eingriff mit
schad-software um die wirtschaft eines
militärischen gegners lahm zu legen und
dabei spielt eine wichtige rolle aber
auch in waffensystemen ist sie längst
integriert und damit geht das risiko
einher dass konflikte sich
verselbstständigen intelligente systeme
sollen unter anderem feindliche raketen
angriffe frühzeitig erkennen und
schneller reagieren können als ein
menschlicher entscheidungsträger mit
entsprechenden vergeltungsschlägen aber
wir wissen von dem beinahe abschuss von
amerikanischen atomraketen wo ein
physikalisches phänomen vorgaukelt dass
die udssr atomraketen schon
abgeschlossen hatte
durch den menschlichen eingriff
verhindert worden ist also doch was wenn
so ein gegenangriff dann
fälschlicherweise eben ausgeführt wird
oder wenn die ki sich wie im
computerhandel mit aktien selbst
hochschaukelt und ein krieg nur durch
die ki auf beiden seiten innerhalb
kürzester zeit eskaliert mit solchen
ethischen fragen hat sich auch das
pentagon beschäftigt also das
amerikanische verteidigungsministerium
nachdem sich das
us-verteidigungsministerium 15 monate
lang mit fachleuten aus der industrie
verwaltung und wissenschaft beraten hat
sind jetzt die ethischen grundsätze des
us-militärs erweitert worden
die neuen leitsätze beruhen auf den
grundsätzen der verantwortlichkeit
gerechtigkeit transparenz und
nachvollziehbarkeit zuverlässigkeit und
regelbarkeit auch hier gilt ähnlich wie
beim straßenverkehr dass wenn die
systeme trotz allem unbeabsichtigtes
verhalten ausführen sie sich nach den
neuen leitlinien ausschalten lassen
können dass diese neuen ethischen
leitlinien eingehalten werden unterliegt
dem ksc dem joint artificial
intelligence center des
verteidigungsministeriums schon diese
beispiele zeigen wie tiefgreifend die
ethischen fragen beim thema ki sind und
sie zeigen auch die haben größtes
problem jeder kocht sein eigenes
richtlinien süppchen eine studie in der
fachzeitschrift nature machine
intelligence zeigt dass sie in den 84
dort analysierten dokumenten zur ethisch
ak ii kein
einziges gemeinsames prinzip findet nur
die themen transparenz gerechtigkeit das
verhindern von schaden verantwortung
sowie datenschutz und privatsphäre
werden zumindest in einigen
gleichermaßen erwähnt enttäuschend ist
auch dass nachhaltigkeit nur in einem
sechstel der dokumente erwähnung findet
und noch krasser
die themen menschenwürde und solidarität
sind noch seltener zu finden
zum einen aufgrund der bisherigen
erfahrungen mit rassistischer ki ist das
höchst fraglich und zum anderen sind
genau das doch die treiber der großen
sorgen rund um ki und auch der
zunehmende energiekonsum und vor allem
die sozialen fragen wie der
restrukturierung des arbeitsmarktes und
damit verbundener jobverluste müssen
berücksichtigt werden denn die ki soll
ja nicht die armen ärmer und die reichen
reicher sondern sie kann und das ist
eben eine riesige chance diese
ungleichheiten aufheben und wohlstand
für alle ermöglichen die studie zeigt
auch dass es schon bei der grundlegenden
definition keine einheitlichkeit gibt
was eigentlich ethische bedeutet wird
überall unterschiedlich wenn ich gar
widersprüchlich definiert natürlich muss
man dazu sagen dass es auch um ein sehr
breites feld an anwendungen geht weil
hinter dem grifka etliche techniken
stecken
ein fehlendes einheitliches verständnis
ist dennoch besorgniserregend denn für
eine technologie die unsere gesellschaft
unser arbeits und alltagsleben so
grundlegend verändern kann als üppigen
prinzip ja alles sind gemeinsame
standards unabdingbar schließlich geht
es am ende doch um etwas sehr
entscheidendes nämlich darum wie
künstliche intelligenz im digitalen
zeitalter für ein besseres leben sorgen
kann
mehr zum thema und anderen umfassend
recherchierten themen aus dem bereich
erfahrt ihr im fachmagazin dix von it
security über big data bis hin zu
embedded systems exklusiv für euch für
klicks um zuschauer und zuschauerinnen
gibt es jetzt eine digitale ausgabe
gratis liegt dafür einfach auf diesen
link oder unten in die video
beschreibung es lohnt sich auf jeden
fall
und hier geht es weiter mit roboter
sofia will menschheit zerstören
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
natürlich diesen kanal klick zum 20
bis dann bleibt dran